all right someone asked me an incredible
question today they said if you had to
pick one idea that could make you a
million dollars this year and it can't
be just a newsletter or a blog or an
agency which are usually our go-tos what
would it be what would you do one
specific idea that you would do and then
he also said and I want to hear one
specific idea that you would do to try
to make a billion dollars that's a good
question and me and Sam are going to
answer that right now on this episode of
my first
[Music]
B
all right what's up we're doing our Q&A
and we got one question that we really
love but is the question Sean is it a
billion dollar in net worth or a company
that's worth a billion dollars I'm going
to say it's a company that's worth a
billion dollars so and you know you own
a big chunk of it okay and what's a bill
what's a billion here or there okay look
the company's worth one billion you're
worth one billion it's all a billion it
changes dramatically so I know a guy who
sold the company for $900 million $990
million you know how much he made after
the sale $3 million that's how much he
made he had he had four co-founders or
maybe five and he raised a ton of money
and they sold it and he made $3 million
that's insane right and I don't I think
that's an extreme case but I think
there's many cases where you create a
billion dollar business and you actually
walk away with like eight% of the
company right which is still a ton of
money but it's that's a wild experience
it's like a small ton it's a
not as big of a ton as people think you
get when you're when you make a company
that big yeah it just the the the
numbers change things a little bit but
let's just get right into it the
million-dollar one what do you have
million dollar one all right so uh you
go first for this one so a million
dollars in is it net worth like and what
do we say three or four years to do it
yeah you got a couple years to do it
you're going to make a million dollars
in profit so to make a million so I
think that there if you want to make a
certain amount of money quickly you have
to ask yourself is it going to come
through annual cash flow or is it going
to come through selling something like
selling a business so for example if you
have a business that's earning let's say
$300,000 a year you in year one you do
50,000 year two you do 200,000 year
three you do 300,000 that's not going to
add up to a million dollars however you
could sell that business for maybe
$900,000 and maybe a million dollars so
collectively you can come up with a
million bucks I think the easiest thing
to do would probably be to sell the
business if you want to make that amount
of money in a certain amount of time in
like three years what I would do so
first do you know Quiet Light brokerage
yes so if I want to make a million
dollars in let's say three years I'm
probably not going to invent anything
new I'm just going to copy what works
and I'm going to try maybe not even do
it better I mean there's four almost 400
million people in America like I can
kind of just figure out someone that
already is doing something and copy it
but put it slightly different ladies and
gentlemen we're not going to be better
faster or cheaper we are simply going to
be also in the business of
yeah strategy yeah the me too strategy
is that what this is like me also no
that's a different thing we don't want
me too we don't want me too we don't
want me too sorry the me also strategy
that's what we'll call it the me also
strategy um so I would probably go to
Quiet Light brokerage so quiet light
brokerage I've had a couple friends sell
and buy businesses through this I've had
uh one friend sell a business via Quiet
Light brokerage for 10 million I had
another Buddy buy a company for 300,000
that ended up
making1 18 million a year in Revenue um
and I know those guys at Quiet Light
brokerage and I've talked to them and
basically quiet like brokerage is a
website where you buy and sell
businesses it's a brokerage meaning it's
not exactly automated but what you can
do is you can see Anonymous descriptions
of companies that are for sale you can
see what the earnings are you can see
what the revenue is you can enter in
your email and they'll send you all the
finan to the all you got to do is say
I'm interested in this business and then
they send you a packet of information
about that business including the name
who the owner is where it's Incorporated
how they got their first customers how
where where they get their customer mix
today what are the areas for growth they
do this fantastic little interview with
the person which is if you're buying the
business very useful but also if you're
executing the me also strategy it is
brilliant and in fact we have a friend
who did this we have a friend who was
looking at one of these websites
saw a business for sale for I think like
$120 or $150,000 one of the smallest
businesses for sale maybe on flipa
somewhere something something like that
and he was like well I don't have
$150,000 but I do have a lot of time to
pick your brain and so he picked the
brains of a bunch of people and then
they were like cool you want to buy it
he's like no but you could you know you
convinced me how uh EAS this is so uh
see you and went and recreated that and
sold it for many millions more and um
that literally did that and I think once
I heard that I realized oh there are
easier ways and harder ways to make $10
million and the easier way is you go
look at businesses that are already
successful and you reverse engineer
which one you could you could create and
copy and by the way I don't think I
think they make you sign an NDA or
something like that so I think you could
get sued if you just rip it off entirely
but I think but and that's not exactly
what I'm suggesting I'm suggesting be
inspired by and do something exactly
like it but slightly
different I can find this client info
have you heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a
CRM platform so it shares its data
across every application every team can
stay aligned no out of sync spreadsheets
or dueling databases HubSpot grow
better well let's just look at it right
now so for example I'm scrolling uh you
go to Qui light or whatever you could
use any of these brokerage sites we we
both like qul light because it's a
little curated so it's it's less filled
with junk even though honestly a lot of
these businesses on here are absolute
junk so let me show you one of these
junk businesses so um you go down to the
kind of like for sale for two million
bucks two million bucks is a nice number
right you could be even a little bit
worse in this business and uh and still
make a million bucks you could if you
sold it for two million after taxes you
have a million dollars all right so here
it is it's a FBA business fulfilled by
Amazon it's a money counting machine
does that mean that they're literally
selling a money counting machine yeah
like I like any business that could be
called a money printing machine a money
counting machine in this they literally
so this says launched in 2020 so three
years ago it says this business sells
money counting machines and counterfeit
build detectors to local businesses
government agencies restaurants
Financial Services Banks event
management companies and nonprofits is
it one like this like this money
counting machine that I have my desk why
you have that right now so I have for
those not give it a run give it a run
that I don't have it I don't have it
plugged in but so I have I literally
have a money counting machine here with
counterfeit money on it when I sold my
company Jack Smith my best friend he
bought me this as like a congratulations
it's $100 I've never used it but I just
like keep it there and when I have
friends that do something interesting
like they sell a company they close a
big deal I send it to them and I say uh
this is either goingon to be a huge like
uh paper weight or you're actually G to
use it good luck and it's a nice gift I
I think this costs
$200 that's actually great we should do
that for the for any fan if you're going
through the process of you're gonna sell
your business
uh just email us and we'll send you the
counter as the good luck as our good
luck charm from us to you uh whenever
and when I have like my cleaning lady
here I'm like just so you know this is
fake money don't even think about
it watch this rip it up yeah I like it's
fake that all this it's 100 grand in
cash that cost $5 that's a great trust
test you should uh just leave it out and
see like you know what not only did you
steal fake money but you're out of a job
too well that's actually a test I do
when I have like new like vendors at my
house is sometimes I'll leave like a few
hundreds there and I know exactly how
much is there and I'll see like what's
going to happen a candy bar and see what
happens uh so someone's selling
literally a money counting machine money
counting machine 1.8 million in revenue
$625,000 of net income net profit so
they're selling it uh here and then if
you go and you you it's a husband and
wife Duo they says they spend this this
is a classic on Quiet Light this is like
the I don't know what Tinder profiles
say nowadays I don't know what the kids
are doing but I know that on every
business for sale the owner spend five
to 10 hours a week on this um they just
don't have enough time and energy to
devote to Growing the business that
anybody who steps in could do uh all
right so anyways I would look at
businesses like this and uh seems like
what you're saying is you would probably
look at what like not one but like maybe
20 to 30 of these just to get a good
idea get enough data points and I would
find out which fits my interest so for
example uh Sean click where they have
membership so they have a membership
category they've got me media which I
know about media so I would do that one
but membership is interesting I think
the reason memberships are interesting
is I think you could have a really
really really Niche Community uh where
you solve a very specific problem and
I'll give you two examples so for like
one could be so if you are if you have a
job you maybe work you know in so you
work in whatever industry and you know
something but you have this problem
called the knowledge complex where you
think well everyone knows this therefore
it's not that interesting to teach and I
think that's actually crazy I think for
like two examples are
automations for HVAC owners another one
is outbound sales for like chiropractors
or uh for Architects and I think what
you can do with things like this is you
can charge pretty high amounts you could
charge $500 a month where you get access
to content that you update on a regular
basis um and then you have a community
where all the other participants can
share tactics and ideas that they're
using to overcome the the problem that
they've all signed up for another
example is um a community where where
you have a database with all the right
people who you need to contact at a c
within a certain niche in order to get a
sale done so for example let's say
you're an agency it could be like here's
all of the buyers of media at the these
companies that you update regularly and
then you could have a community where
people are discussing tactics and
strategies in order to accomplish that
task and I think when you look at like
the the the problem or you're you're
thinking about what the customer is
going through when they're going to buy
this which is well if I spend $3,000 a
year on this if I only get one sale this
is worth it for me and I got a positive
Roi and I think that sale is
significantly easier than selling to
Consumers where you're having to do a
lot of guess work with this if you do
$3,000 a year in order to get to a
million dollar sale you'd have to look
at what those multiples are but I think
the multiples on the membership sites
are like five times profit so get to a
million need $250,000 in profit to get
to $250,000 in profit on a
$3,000 year service it could be just you
and a part-time employee or one
full-time employee I don't know what
that match is but you don't need that
many customers in order to hit that
Target and so I would do that over a
consumer product because I can just talk
to my customers and they could tell me
exactly what they want and I'm basically
providing a service that they're
requesting on a regular basis in order
to keep them here's a specific example
of that uh exit five I think is the name
of it um exit 5 is like a community of
B2B marketers and uh I don't know what
they pay per year it's a little bit less
than what you just said but I think they
could be charging you know more like
$2500 or $3,000 but the big idea here is
go get a 100 people paying you three
grand a year and you can even make it
exclusive be like this is a community
for only 150 of the top B2B marketers in
the world we're gonna we're going to
invite you in and then you're going to
share ideas plus we have this database
of whatever whether it's ad creative
that works we have this database of
vendors or you know buyers with their
contact info and we all openly share
here it's a it's a sort of give to get
uh you know model and um yeah the thing
is probably worth two three million
bucks right now that that this guy's
made and and you know 500 to a th
members and the reason if you're
starting from scratch is you don't need
that particularly big of an audience you
don't need to you you'd cold email
people you would also build an audience
but in order to get to a let's say you
have an audience of 5,000 people which
is very attainable to get particularly
if you give it a year you only need
about 100 to 200 people to buy what
you're selling in order to hit that
Target and you so your podcast doesn't
need to be huge your Twitter handle your
cold email outbound strategy doesn't
need to be huge and so that's probably
what I would do to get to a million
dollars what do you think about that
well you have you basically said two
ideas right that was a two for one
special you had go to quiet light or a
business
brokerage and find a business that you
can either reverse engineer or
legitimately so you know reverse
engineer we kind of say and that's I
would say a little bit generously let's
call it Scrappy the scrappy way to do
things you don't have any money you uh
you know you need to get I you know
rather than just try to come up with an
idea from Scrat scratch when you're kind
of a beginner the better way is to go
learn what businesses actually work how
they work why they work go look at 30 to
50 that's like a real world NBA that you
picked up and then find one of those
that you think you could mimic and put
your own twist on right that's that's
idea one you had by the way with that
comes also you could just buy the
business so for a lot of these even a $2
million business you can um go get an
SBA loan a lot of these will say that
they're SBA loan eligible so let's say
that you're in the United you can go get
SBA loan put down 10 to 15% so if you
can go get 200 Grand you could buy a $2
million business that's doing 600 600k
of profit um per year and so you could
actually go buy that business and just
try to grow it because actually getting
a business from Zer in Revenue to 2
million in revenue or 1.8 million in
revenue is pretty hard relative to
taking a business that's at 1.8 and
getting it to 3.1 million for example
like you know adding an extra million of
Revenue to a business already working is
actually much easier than going from Zer
to one I think you got both options on
the table there it's just more
risk well yeah there's there's a little
bit more risk because you're personally
liable for the for the for the loan
there so you know you have to buy a good
business you have to you have to be able
to know what a good business is and
that's where maybe some mentors could
help um the other business the other
idea you said was basically a membership
service a membership a membership
Community for some Niche right that's
kind of like a separate idea it has to
solve a specific problem so a lot of
these like you'll see a lot out there
that are memberships for launching a
business that's not spec that's not
nearly specific enough it's has to be
geared towards employees and and like
there's a clear beginning middle and end
and there's an outcome uh and there's a
clear Roi as opposed to like
accountability or whatever it is you
know what I mean right right right
nothing soft and fluffy um all right so
those are good I think those are really
good in fact I think the first one you
said is I think the right answer um
that's what I would in reality that's
what I would go do but to make it fun
I'm gonna come up with some other ideas
so is that what you had uh that's what I
would it's like if it was my cousin and
my cousin's like yo how do I do this I'd
be like all right look this is what
we're doing um you need to do this worst
case scenario you're going to go learn
what a bunch a bunch a bunch of
blueprints for successful businesses and
maybe you don't pull the trigger on any
of them but still was a good use of your
time and best case scenario you find one
of these that you say I could do that
and either you buy it or you're G to
Like Remix it and create your own
version of that so that is I think the
right answer the second right answer
would be an e-commerce company because
it's not hard to build an e-commerce
brand either on on Amazon or or on
Shopify that can sell for a million
dollars but kind of again a boring
answer so I'm going to give you a more
fun answer
so here is uh here's one
idea the four most beautiful letters in
the English language are
qsbs all right so what's the qsbs idea
you're going to create a qsbs advisory
firm what is that that's super Niche H
technically this might be considered an
agency but but I think we'll allow it
because it's so specific in Niche here
and off the beaten path so here's what
you're going to do now when any company
starts uh a tech company starts that's
going to be qsbs eligible that qsbs
eligibility is worth you have to say
what qsbs is oh sorry qsbs is a tax
treatment for qualified small business
stock what that means is that if you're
a business that fits like these five
criteria which most tech companies fit
then when you sell if you've held the
stock for five years or even if it's a
little bit less than that you can still
kind of roll it over um your first $10
million of your gain are going to be
tax-free not only most tech companies
most new C Corps that hold for five
years would would would fall there are
some exceptions like you can't do it if
you're a doctor or lawyer or real estate
like there are things that are excluded
but again that's kind of the point here
is qsbs advisory we're going to help you
figure out are you eligible or not
and we're going to provide a letter that
says we attest to the you know the
belief that this is going to be
qualified small business stock now why
is this easy to do why is my strategy
this well if I'm trying to make money
it's kind of like you described with the
membership I need to create 10 times
more than I'm taking right this is a
general rule of life that's probably a
good rule of Life create more value than
you're trying to take and that's what
I'd be trying to do here so I was
looking for something where with a small
amount of work I could create a lot of
value for my customer well all that
sounds generic but like in this case if
my stock is going to be qsbs uh
eligible that might save me $10 million
down the road and that's a pretty big
huge benefit so would I pay $5,000 or
$10,000 for um you know in legal fees in
order to in advisory fees in order to um
protect my possible $10 million gain I
would and I think a lot of people do and
so what what I would do here is I would
build a advisory firm that says we are
qsbs
experts we know the ins and outs of qsbs
were respected um I would hire maybe
lawyers or accountants that have done
this before and I would say hey on a as
needed basis I'm gonna when I get a
customer I will pay you whatever $300 an
hour $500 an hour for your time to do an
assessment and write a letter that
basically assesses the eligibility you
think for qsbs now qsbs is not like a
black and white thing um it's not like a
qsbs is basically when you when you get
the sale you declare you say This falls
under qsbs but if you ever got audited
you'd have to be able to protect you
know uh defend that why did you say it
was qsbs eligible and so what companies
and individuals do is they will go to go
get a letter that basically says we as
experts have looked at this business and
we believe that this is going to be qsbs
this is qualified small business stock
you know like the 409 what's what's it
called the 409 409 so when in order to
do a bunch of stuff with your business
you a lot of times tech companies have
to get valued every year for year every
year you should get valued and then that
also is necessary when you want to issue
new stock or whatever uh for employees
or for investors you typically set a
benchmark for but there's a lot of
companies that do this as a service
where you sp you spend five or15 to
$10,000 and you don't actually give them
that much information you give them your
financials and then they ask you to
submit like 10 publicly traded
competitors and then they just like say
all right we think that your valuation
is blank and you you spend five to
10,000 I think for that you're basically
you want it to be low usually so usually
what you're trying to do is get a low
409a so that everybody's options are
priced low um so it's like not not even
like you're trying to justify a high
valuation you're actually trying to
justify a low valuation in most Cas and
it's kind of crony capitalism a little
bit like they'll like yeah yeah yeah
we'll make it low they we'll be fair and
then they wink at you uh and they like
set it really low but uh yeah basically
you're you're what you're suggesting is
doing the same thing for qsbs which is 4
is equally valid idea but what I would
do is I would I would create this for
what I like about the qsbs thing is it's
a little bit higher ticket so typically
these people will charge let's say10 to
15,000 for the initial attestation
letter I don't know if I'm saying that
word right um but then on top of that
you could even charge kind of like an
ongoing fee because there are all these
like foot faults so it's not just like a
there is some genuine help so for
example oh you're going to sell
secondary there's things you might do
wrong when you sell secondary that could
disqualify you there's disqualifying
events and so uh you know you can't bill
for Revenue in specific ways if it's
categorized as X it might take you out
of qsbs Eligibility and so it's just an
insurance policy it's a cover your ass
it's a legal thing it's something people
don't want to do themselves it's too
high risk do yourself um and you
literally can't do it yourself because
you can't write the letter for yourself
and so so uh you don't have to have it
but it is a nice to have and what I
would do is I would go scare the living
out of every tech company that I
find on crunch base and I would say
don't you want this $10 million
exclusion for you it's it's per person
by the way it's not per company so it's
per tax return so let's say there's a
company with that's gonna be gonna be
big every single one of those Executives
is going to want their stock to be qsbs
eligible and so I would go to them and I
would scare the living out of them
that they might get this wrong and I
would tell them don't don't worry we can
cover this for you and here's how we'll
cover it for you pay us whatever either
the lump sum up front or a monthly
recurring fee or an annual recurring
fee5 $1,500 a year $2,000 a year and we
will uh kind of make sure we're your
advisory on that so that you know you're
covered at the end of the day that's a
pretty brilliant idea actually you know
if you just think about it right how do
you get to let's say we talked about to
sell a company for over a million
dollars let's just round up and say you
got to have
$300,000 of um of annual net profits so
how do you get to 300,000 of annual net
profits if you're charging you know
roughly $110,000 a year you only need 30
customers a year 30 customers a
year I've taking shits bigger than that
come on if you can't get to a million
dollars this way you can't get it anyway
right I think what holds a lot of people
back would be there's not going to be a
bunch of these so there this is not like
you can't bring up 10,000 of these like
you know social media marketing agencies
there going to be a million of those um
you have to have some expertise or
partner with people who have expertise
so they you know some of the some of the
the mechanics of how to do it but man
there's niches and riches and like
that's not that hard to do to get to
there so many upsells to that which is
like the key to selling a company is
they say all right well how does this
grow and you say well do these companies
also need a 409 409a do they also need
these other legal services do they of
course they do that's how you do it and
you and you sell the dream a little bit
of what the expansion Revenue comes from
and the key here is you don't need to be
a law firm so there's rule all kinds of
rules around who can own a law firm you
don't actually have to be a law firm to
do this because it's not legal work it's
advisory and it's like some blend of
like legal accounting and just advisory
and so I think because of that you don't
need to be a law firm if you do this and
by the way I've worked with somebody who
does this if anybody actually needs this
letter feel free to email me I'll I'll
I'll route you to the guide you can you
can actually use this because what are
you going to be like the mob and take a
cut for making the introduction you
should
I got to get my beak wet too all
right uh that's actually better than my
idea by the way because I actually think
this is simpler because it's already a
service others are providing and you're
just
basically connecting yeah yeah so uh I
would look for things like that I had
like five other ideas that would fit
this but okay for this exercise we're
doing one now let's move on to the main
event the billion dollar idea by the way
do I get a thrill of the shill before we
get to the billion dollar idea oh hold
on what time is it it is is time for the
thrill of the shill Sam you are up your
first time providing the thrill of the
shill for those who don't know this is
where we shamelessly shill one of our
companies but we have to do it in a
thrilling way meaning we got to provide
some value some entertainment some
insight we got to provide something a
little something we gotta have
attributes if we're gonna do this here
we go Thrill of the show I'm gonna try
and keep this one short because this
this might be a short episode but
basically I remember in
2017 I went to NerdWallet nerdwallet.com
I went to their office Tim Chen was the
CEO and founder he invested in the
hustle and I remember being like Tim I'm
freaking out man my expenses went up
because of payroll from 30,000 to
$80,000 a month and at the time they had
just rented Twitter's old office and
they were you know they probably had a
payroll of $3 million a month or maybe
even $5 million a month and I remember
he looked at me funny and he was like
trying to be empathetic and he was nice
and and he kind of like was nice by
saying oh wow wow yeah I understand and
I was like Tim I'm so stressed out about
this and what he said to me was
basically look you kind of have to
detach yourself and your payroll needs
to just you just it's just a number on
an Excel sheet and you just have to like
figure out how do I deploy this much
money here and what's my outcome going
to be and what's my profit going to be
and that didn't sit well with me until
about 12 months ago so I launched this
company called Hampton um join
hampton.com it's like a community for
Founders who are doing at least a
million in Revenue but the average memb
is like 25 million a year and I remember
like that me out forever we had a team
Retreat last week and I went out there
and right now we've got 16 full-time
employees or 15 including me and then
we've also employed I think 50
facilitators now so in like 18 months
we've created what's that 70 or 65 jobs
something like that and I am so not
stressed about it this year this is the
only time I've not been stressed about
payroll and providing people because the
way that we've looked at it is exactly
how Tim has explained where it's just
like what's my input what's my output
and this idea of being like a capital
allocator I've never had that where it's
like been as clearcut as well I hire
this person I get this much out after
three months it's completely changed how
I've um how I've run this company and
it's made me so much more relaxed and I
don't know what made that shift other
than his conversation but you know what
I'm talking about have you ever like
been through this well we both used to
be kind of like oh if you're an
entrepreneur you're a product maker and
like we'd be sitting there writing you
know you're right the hustle and you
know I'm sitting there in in designing
things and working with the engineers
trying to make a product but there is an
up level of that which is as once you
build the product and the product has
which Hampton does has product Market
fit people like it they use it they
they're in it now you're a capital
allocator basically you're take you're
you're just deciding where resources go
so um I need to be able to like you
can't be tight on money because money is
your job you have to deploy that in a
way that's going to get more output than
the input and sometimes you'll you're
not going to be 100% but no knowing that
that's the job makes it easier and it
sounds like having the right
conversation at the right time from
somebody who's appearer of yours was the
key yeah and that's by the way what the
one of the whole things about Hampton is
that you have peers with other
entrepreneurs that are of similar size
company uh that that that you have and
anyway that like learning I remember
having our team offsite at previous
companies and I'm like H like this
person just had a baby basically I just
had a baby how am I going to create
enough Revenue in order to like provide
for this kid cuz that's how it feels at
first or you're like no you
didn't I did remember yeah like I the
one who did that hey Jess when's our
baby
shower just and this year it's been or
or you'll be like this person cost
$250,000 there's no way that's a fair
salary it's like well that's a house
where I'm from are you a house like yeah
can I live in you you have three beds
and a bath it's not I'm not paying you
$250,000 so that's been my biggest
takeaway this year with running Hampton
so anyway if you're particularly if
you're listening to this and you do at
least 50 million in Revenue we're
building groups for that join
hampton.com all right let's do uh the
billion dollar one you want me to go
first can I go first okay go all right
I'm gonna steal one of your lines so
Sean what if I told you I had an
idea this is line I'm leaning what what
if I told I had an idea that Elon Musk
himself would be bigger than Tesla would
that interest you I'd be fairly
interested keep going do you know who uh
I think his name is Kai Fu Lee do you
know who that investor is he's the uh no
sounds awesome though he's a famous
Chinese investor basically one of the
early guys at Apple early at Google he
wrote a great book about why China's
amazing uh in terms of like why they're
going to beat America and he was saying
that this thing is going to replace 40%
of jobs inside the next 12 years would
that interest you I would love to
replace 40% of jobs in the next 12 years
I think
that now if you're thinking I'm talking
about AI you're wrong here's here here's
what it is it's humanoids humanoids
that's what that's the technical term
basically imagine RoboCop or imagine
machines and I think that this whole uh
business of humanoids which is robots to
automate a lot of processes but a lot of
people think like just blue collar job
but that's not entirely true it's like
every type of job so Elon Musk said that
um that Tesla has is working on
humanoids I think it's called Optimus is
what it's called and he went on to say
that uh like at a recent investor call
he was like not a lot of you people are
talking about Optimus are robots but I
think that's crazy because this is
actually going to be bigger than our car
business bigger than self-driving bigger
than solar it's going to be bigger than
everything and I don't think you guys
realize how big this is going to be I
invested in this company uh in a space
called figure and I talked to Brett
Adcock we had him on here here and he
basically has me convinced that this is
going to be like the biggest industry
mover the in the next like 10 or 15
years and I think that what I would do
you invested in figure yeah is that is
that did I tell you that for the 30th
time no no no no I've never told you
that that's funny but uh what
valuation $300 million I think okay
that's not bad and I invested bad but
it's not that bad well I invest and I
invested a lot for me which I think is
around $60
,000 well yeah he's like your hero so
you know you actually just paid for some
time with yeah I paid for Access I paid
for him to reply to a text uh but
basically that that was a lot of money
for me I don't normally invest that much
but my reasoning is is like this could I
could see it going out of business which
is incredibly likely I could see it
selling for $3 billion or I could see it
becoming like a $50 billion company um
but it's like any Angel investment I
think the likelihood of it going out of
business is incredibly High but
basically here's my
reasoning if you or why reasoning why I
think this could be a big company I
think this is going to be like one of
the biggest things that happens in the
next 15 years I think that the people
who are working on this space are
typically like hardcore uh Hardware
engineering nerds and I think that I
could spend a year going to every Meetup
going to car car melon which I think a
lot of these folks come from and I think
I could find a handful of people and do
a really good job of organizing these
people around company I think that I
could do a good job of cold emailing the
Brett ax of the world and getting in
with them as well as some of the older
guys in the space and making them like
open up to me and say what are
tangentially like the areas that you're
not attacking that are interesting I
think I can get them to explain to me uh
these problems I think that um I think
this is so big that there's going to be
more of these robots than there are
humans and I also think that when you in
order to create a billion dollar company
or a company that can net you a billion
dollars that's just you have to go huge
and you I think that the odds are what
I'm doing personally in my life I don't
have a goal becoming a billionaire but I
think that could happen is I'm creating
companies that sell for a small amount
of money and then I'm letting
compounding kind of like do the rest
that's going to take me 50 or 80 years
who knows how long that's going to take
me but if you want to make it in a short
amount of time you pretty much have to
raise VC and you have to do it in an
industry that's like a Title Wave where
you're just trying to catch that wave if
you want to do it in like 10 years
rather um and so I think I would go into
the humanoid space what do you think
about that well as you know I love that
idea because I was going to say that
idea and you said no can I say that idea
today and I said all that's not what I
said I said I said literally read that
out already can I have that will you
send me that and I'll say it with my
lips and I was like all right fine bro
um well let me tell you something
interesting all right let me add to it
so
obviously 100% agree I think I I
actually was specifically thinking like
um warehouse robots like I would even
just kind of narrow it down and be like
all right uh if I was really going to do
this I would try to figure out what job
in a warehouse I can eliminate by using
a robot um which is what like packing
boxes B I would look at the minimum wage
labor class and I would say um nobody
wants minimum wage essentially the
workers don't want to be minimum wage
the employers don't want to pay minimum
wage and get like kind of a flaky output
and so I had a friend once that was
telling me he's like uh I invest in
companies with no product Market fit
risks my friend V and I said what do you
mean I've never I just thought every
startup has product Market fit risk
that's the whole point you're trying to
get to product Market fit he goes no I
invest with no product Market fit risk I
never heard that before and he goes I'm
just looking for technical risk meaning
if you could build it the job is done
and he's like of course you'll still go
sell it but like there it will be so
easy at that point the market will
obviously absorb this if it can actually
do it there are many things like this so
like self-driving if you can actually
make self safe self-driving cars cars
that do not crash that are you know uh
self-driving and obviously there's
always the edge cases but there's
infinite market demand for people not to
want to be driving and sitting in
traffic and having their car parked
instead of having it go run around and
earn the money by dropping people off
and so he his idea you know he invested
in this pizza robot company so it was
like basically which was awesome Zoom
yeah well there was there was like a few
of them at the time I don't think any of
them worked out there's always like
these waves and it's like it was too
early the tech wasn't there and all the
companies crash and burn but like the
next wave should start right now and
actually that's maybe where I would go
with this so he's like you know if
you're Domino's do you want to pay you
know whatever I don't know what they pay
$15 an hour for somebody who's gonna
call in sick they're going to be
checking their phone they're going to be
goofing off they're going to be eating
pepperonis off the pizzas they're gonna
you know uh they're going to get in
fights with the other people there and
you know then they leave and then you
have to replace them and then you have
to train that new person or would you
rather buy one machine that prints a
perfect pizza every single time 247
never never calls in sick never
complains never asks you for more money
never asks for a raise never spits in
the food never does would you rather
have that it's like oh of course you
would always have the robot that makes
the perfect pizza and he's like making a
pizza is incredibly like it's a it's a
sandboxed thing it's like not like a
robot that can do anything it's a
specific robot that can make a pizza it
can flatten the dough into a perfect
circle apply the cheese apply the sauce
whatever bake it for a certain time and
then put it in the box and cut it and
like that's what that needs to do and
I'm going to you know so so what I would
do is I would go and do exactly what you
said like go to MIT go to Carnegie melon
and be like hey guys we're building a
pizza robot and when we do there's
whatever how many pizza chains you know
how many pizza restaurant location how
many pizza chains in the US and by the
way there was a company called Zoom Zoom
Zoom I forget that went out of business
and people made fun of them they're like
in the headlines they got totally mocked
they raised $500
million that was cool and that definely
could have work I think they screwed it
up they like went they like made
restaurants that you could go to that
that was not right there's 80,000 Pizza
chain pizza restaurants in the country
880,000 and you would start with the
chains because the chains actually have
the most to gain by doing this right
they they budgets they'll they'll sign
letters of intent like I remember when
boom supersonic the airplane company
came out at YC and they were like yeah
we have a hundred million purchase order
from Like Richard Branson if we could
build this plane they're going to buy it
so now the question is do you think me
and packing nerds behind me can build
this plane that's the bet and like
whether you do or don't believe it that
was the BET and I like that idea I'll
I'll tell you another thing about the
robotics thing before I like test I like
Tech RIS a little bit more than like
demand RIS for sure yeah yeah I agree me
me too um even though that's not at all
how I've you know thought about it
before but if I was gonna go try to
build a billion- dollar company I would
go try to build one with only Tech risk
and not demand risk um so there's here
I'm GNA tell you a little little story
here so shout out to this guy Abe you
probably don't know Abe but his boss
Kevin Ryan came on the Pod so Kevin Ryan
comes on the Pod he's fascinating but
like he had this Aura of I'm a badass
who does badass things but I'm kind of
busy and so
uh of course Ben applied Ben's law so
the the Ben's law for those who don't
know is you don't try to contact Sean
you contact Ben Ben is the faster more
approachable smarter better better human
being to to approach and get the Insight
on and and get in touch with me than
trying to go to me directly and so Ben
applied Ben's law Ben goes and he finds
Kevin Ryan's Ben and so he finds the
number two that's you know like there
and so he finds this guy Abe Abe Murray
and uh I was I'm subscribed to Abe's
newsletter and he just had a good one
which he goes um he goes why the
consensus view of Robotics is wrong and
he goes I think that most people think
you know the future of robots is is this
humanoid and maybe a humanoid that walks
and has arms and legs uh is the is the
eventual solution but that might be too
far out right now and actually we should
look at the most successful robot in the
world today what is it the dishwasher
it's installed in everybody's home
already it's a robot dishwasher it
replaced that job of having to wash
dishes for you know the majority of
homes he goes it doesn't have arms and
legs it doesn't look like a human it is
a purpose-built robot that one specific
need and they have some company called
renovate Robotics and the picture is
basically it's a robot that sits on a
roof that does Roofing jobs so it'll go
and it'll replace a roof basically it
just goes up and down your roof uh you
know or like not replace but like you
know uh lay down the roof or whatever
like you know install a roof on a on a
home and he's like if this works it's
going to be he's like we just did the
first robotically installed roof if this
works again you have lower cost higher
quality more like consistency uh more
availability you know for for roofing
companies and so I like this idea of
these purpose-built specific robots the
equivalent of dishwashers and pizza
making robots and Roofing robots uh if I
was going to do the billion dollar idea
that's what I would do but I'll listen
to their home page their homeage is
labor is the biggest challenge for
roofers our robots make roofers twice as
productive and improve safety by
reducing work at height easy that's an
easy sale another and I'll another
reason why robots are interesting is you
are only working within the laws of
physics and the laws of physics I find I
find those to be a bit easier to work in
compared to say creating the next Louis
Vuitton like to creating a brand or
consumer product I actually think it's
more complicated than just saying well I
like because that's an infinite number
of options within Hardware it's just
like it's just like so much simpler and
straightforward versus generating demand
or creating a brand that people love or
creating a social product that people
love which is so much more rare and more
challenging have you heard Elon Musk
quote uh the the only real laws are
physics everything else is a
recommendation no but that's
brilliant uh all right so that's a great
idea I think these uh purpal robots um
that's a great idea I came up with says
you well I'm saying that's these these
these this robot idea I think is is the
right idea um any by the way here's a
way to like create more luck like this
our buddy furcon uh has this space in
San Francisco called Founders Inc f. in
and what he did I was like so what's the
plan he's like I'm just going to recruit
like the smartest hackers I can find and
just be like hey here's a free office
here I'm gonna help you out and I'm
gonna invest in you before you even know
what the hell you're doing and uh I'm
gonna help you get these off the ground
I was like well that's great but how are
you gonna get the best hackers he goes
I'm gonna give him toys like what do you
mean toys he goes I took the first floor
of the entire office there there's no
desks it's just a hardware robotics lab
he's like so I'm buying like 3D printers
drones laser cutting equipment robotic
arms stuff that the average hacker can't
buy you know the average you know 22y
old engineer can't go buy this you know
$15,000 thing or $30,000 thing but Fon
can buy it and he's like I'm just gonna
make it available for free and come in
here and work on it and so now he's got
in that lab there's a guy who's got a
brain device that you put on your head
and it like makes you more focused
there's a guy who's there's a company
called Orange Wood Labs that basically
they have this robotic arm that can um
do whatever you program it to do so when
I went in there they were like watch
we're g to make it uh you know make a
margarita watch this uh we can make this
and the the application they're doing is
painting or like I don't know powder
coating or something like that yeah
powder Co like you ever done powder
coating and I was like no you know what
dangerous I was like no stop asking me
questions and they're like well I think
everything is powder coater yeah it's
basically like how you you know you do
it on Floors you do it on any metals or
whatever like for a car or something
like that so they were like yeah this
thing can powder coat basically better
and faster like automatically um and so
it could do jobs at like you know one
fifth of the price of a human being
because we just give him the robot the
robot just goes and does it and then it
comes home and that's it and so I was
like oh interesting um but there's a lot
of people building stuff like this and
one way to increase their indiy is to
like go to these kind of Hardware Labs
or go find out where they hang out and
just go talk to people see what they're
what they're building and they people
who do thisal they're not they're not a
lot of them don't care about business a
lot of them are unorganized it's like
the the typical like scientist who wears
like who forgets to put one sock on and
only wears like one sock or like their
shoes on on the wrong foot it's like
they're just like these brilliant people
who don't necessarily care about stuff
and I think if you can be the organizer
you can win um what do you have all
right so my path to a billion uh do you
want the dark idea or you want the light
idea do you want the the good idea or
the evil idea which one do you
want I don't know uh that's I want to go
dark I think but okay give you both but
I'll do the dark one fast so here's the
here's the big pitch for the dark
idea andil for some other
country you could figure the rest out
from there uh what Palmer lucky has done
with andril for the US defense
department do it for Israel do it for do
it for another country go find a country
that wants you know Advanced weapons
technology and be like cool I'm going to
recruit the brightest mines and we're
going to give us like you know 50
million to 150 million dollar contract
and we'll get started here dude Palmer's
on a tear lately I would literally go
look at the road map for Andre I'd be
like oh they built this like uh missile
that can fly itself you know and lives
in this like vending machine I don't
know if you saw that video of like yes
amazing heet inside I'd be like cool do
pick from the Ander Roll menu we're
going to figure out how to build those
and you guys will own the IP that's what
I would do if I really had to you know
if I was if I wanted to go into more of
the the gray or dark areas where it's
you know there's a bit of war and
destruction involved but here's the
light idea here's another
idea
um we're buying a university okay so
what are we doing there are a lot of
colleges for sale more than you would
think uh are they on they're on Deal
stream so go to a website called
dealstream come on that was kind of
funny well they could be deal stream is
literally like Quiet Light it's just
different name it's the same idea it's a
business Bridge uh but if you look
colleges for sale they're they're there
and they're not that expensive you could
buy colleges for like $5 million $10
million so to do this you're going to
need a lot of money but the good news is
that universities are worth a lot of
money like what would you Peg the value
at let's start at the top end like what
do you think Stanford or Harvard is
worth if somebody really if Mega
billionaire genius wanted to buy
Stanford or Harvard what what would it
even cost could
would it be like a a Harvard hundred
plus billion dollars I mean the
endowment alone I think is like what the
endowment alone is almost h100 billion
do right so yeah it's hard to even the
whole inada has got to be 500 billion it
might like these are companies that are
worth sorry universities are essentially
properties that are
worth you know a Facebook they're crazy
they're crazy Harvard endowments is is
53 billion so yeah I don't know they it
100 to 200 300 billion something like
that yeah like so big that it's hard to
understand hard to even fathom right not
for sale can't be bought essentially
same thing with Stanford now let's even
go to like a Belmont right so like let's
just do some quick math here where I
went Belmont University you went to
Belmont what's the tuition at Belmont
back then it was 30,000 let's see what
it is now Belmont University tuition
$38,000 all right so $38,000 and how
many students go to Belmont let's say
5,000 5,000 uh per year per year per or
the whole whole university you could say
um let's say 1,800 per year all right so
let's go let's Round Up to 2,000 so even
a small small private SCH where where
Isabel I don't even know where it is
Nashville Tennessee it looks like they
have 7,300 students so 2,000 per class
let's say cool so 76 million dollar
Topline that's not counting endowments
that's not counting gr grants and
research it's not counting the facts
that it's tax-free that it's has like
all these other benefits like we so you
can actually see see the numbers by the
way the Belmont's uh annual
revenue is $464 million their expenses
are $350 million so they make $100
million a year in profit they only have
$200 million in liabilities and they
have $1.5 billion in
asset and that's for
a nowhere University so that's the game
plan we're we're building one of those
now what are we going to do so we're
going to go buy one what are we buying
we're essentially buying two things I
want the campus and I want the liquor
license and by liquor license I mean the
accreditation as long as it's already
accredited I want have to go through
that
process now uh why do I want a campus
Because I want the land I want the
buildings I want the depreciation I want
a physical place because I think it adds
to The Prestige um we will have a large
online component but whatever now the
main go goal here is we got to Brand
this school and so what are we going to
do we're going to make it a bit of a
luxury product meaning it's going to be
only for the elite of the elite so um
you know we have to have a lower
acceptance rate than Harvard we have to
be known for we're going to sponsor
competitions for like mathlete type of
competitions hardcore science
competitions we are going to go around
the country to high schools and
basically be like we're going after
Gamers programmers and hardcore math
kids and we're going to sponsor ton of
competitions guess what those
sponsorships cost pizza the currency is
essentially you provide free pizza there
is no competition when I was doing our
Esports company that we sold to Twitch I
was like all right we want to create the
world's biggest high school Esports
league and we did in like less than a
year guess what it
cost like 450 pizzas is what it cost me
to like sponsor these programs uh it
cost nothing and so we're going to go
and we're going to first we're g to get
in front of them now uh when I why did I
go to Duke University I went because
like in fifth grade Duke did something
called the Nationwide Talent
identification program and I'll be
damned if my mom didn't want to find out
if her kid was talented and so we take
this test and we take this test and is
that like the Indian version of like a
uh like one of those model competitions
they have at the mall when you were 12
yeah it's a beauty it's like sports but
for brown people so um so my mom puts me
in this I really I I think every kid in
my school took it they just went to the
school and they were like Hey we're
trying to identified the most talented
gifted and talented kids also parents
can you put your uh income on the
statement as well
so exactly that impacts your IQ a little
bit and uh you know we got to get paid
so I got a scoreback and a goodie bag
and literally the goodie bag was a
Rubik's Cube and I I don't know what the
hell was going on but whatever that is
I'm going to go find the marketing
coordinator that did this Duke Talent
identification program we're stealing
that we're going to go get them while
they're young fifth sixth grades we're
going to be identifying these special
you know special gift and talented kids
uh so we're making it super prestigious
you already know the name's gonna have
some old money right you know you
know um you know we're
going I've already done this before with
the private school names but like
bridgemont Oakland or walf
uh Kennedy exceler yeah exactly so we're
definitely going that way um we're gonna
have our own entrance exam so we don't
take the SATs because we're not peasants
and so you're gonna uh we're going to go
from City to city and we're going to
have our own entrance exam it's going to
be a Sixpoint exam uh I don't know what
that means but I let's just say that's
what it is um now what else are we going
to do you know these speaker bureaus
where you can go pay like $50,000 for
Obama to speak yeah we're doing that
more like $2 million for Obama but yeah
okay well we're we got a budget all
right and the budget gonna be like we
have like a $6 million speaker budget so
when I'm raising this money for this I'm
gonna basically raise 50 to$ 75 million
maybe $100 million for this and a lot of
that is front-loaded in brand building
and one of the things we're going to do
is about five to six million dollars a
year at speaker fees and so I'm
basically goingon to pull the Sam
bankman freed without the fraud so you
know s bank freed took the money and
basically was like how do I everybody
that FTX is like a thing and it's
legitimate he's like Tom Brady um Larry
David Steph Curry this Arena oh uh this
guy is like a super connector in
Hollywood I'm gonna put a hundred
million dolls into his fund and now he's
gonna make he's gonna get me you know
dinner with Bill Bill and Hillary
Clinton and like that's what he
literally did and although he did a
bunch of screwed up things honestly it's
kind of inspiring the way he just threw
his weight around using money to like
build a brand um if he had not literally
stolen money from customer deposits to
do so that would have just been an
incredible uh approach by an
entrepreneur like it actually would have
been very like lauded of how he did it
in the same way that like you know Uber
is is sort of praised for the way it
just like brute forced its way into
different cities and actually like built
a huge Global brand so that's what I
would do so speaker fees those are going
on the website those are going viral um
to get those people to do like kind of
speeches to our kids um and we're going
to also spend a ton of money on Direct
marketing so no University really goes D
Toc except for the low-end University of
Phoenix type of um that's crazy and
by the way they are amazing at it they
are really at it they buil5 billion
business doing it in the world of like
direct response there's like Financial
newsletters then there's like Omaha
Stakes who like crushes it and the
stamps.com world and ere erectile
dysfunction and then like video game
people and then universities University
of Phoenix crushes it I think I think
them and like full sale are in the top
like 20 of Spenders on Google yeah yeah
exactly and you know it Technical
Institute of running TV ads and stuff
like that that's what I would do so I'd
basically go through podcasts I'm going
to blanket them every every intellectual
podcast that parents listen to I'm going
to blanket it with with ads for this um
and the ads aren't apply apply now come
here the ads are going to be about how
hard it is to get in about it's going to
be more native stuff about controversy
is it right or wrong that the school is
so hard to get into that it's only for
the gifted and talented that they're
discriminating and only allowing the
smart kids in and I would actually drum
up controversy around that in order to
uh to build the brand because there's no
better brand than a brand that of
something you can't get into so there's
this amazing article that says lessons
you can learn from for-profit
universities on cosper click advertising
the University of Phoenix in the last
five years has spent $3 billion do in
marketing on Google alone it's estimated
they're spending roughly $5 million a
month and they receive roughly 70,000 to
880,000 clicks per month off of Google
that's insane that is insane that's wild
now what else would I do okay so I'm
spending a ton of money on ads um I
hired the best branding agency in the
world I'm spending money on the speakers
fees again I'm spending spending
spending now how do I make money okay
well obviously you have things like your
tuition but I actually think there's
another another way you could do this it
involves my good old friend nfts okay so
uh hear me out hear me out you're going
to respect this idea when you're hear
have you ever seen when a stadium
launches that they sell something called
psls do you know what those are is that
like season ticket holders for a certain
period of time or like founding Club
think you're paying 225 $50,000 oh you
must be getting tickets no no no you got
a personal seat license and the license
just allows you to buy the ticket you
can't even buy the ticket without the
license so literally imagine every chair
in the stadium and they basically have
their own license each one has its own
license you have to buy the license in
order to buy the tickets once you buy
the tickets now you can now you can sell
it now you can sell the license you can
sell whatever right they use this to
fundraise so I kind of had this idea
around universities which was if I
wanted to start a university let's say
it was going to have you know 5,000 or
10,000 students a year well why wouldn't
I sell 10,000 why wouldn't I mint a
10,000 nft package for around this and
again I built the brand up I have a real
story here unlike most nfts I have a
real story and the story is
this what would it be worth to buy a
seat at Harvard to own one seat in every
admissions class in Harvard you could
use it for your own kid you could gift
it out as a scholarship or you could
sell it to somebody who wants to go to
yeah because the the rental property the
value of a good diploma it should go up
every decade so like a Belmont
University they don't have any street
cred so like my value isn't going up a
Harvard a Stanford goes up but then if
they have a controversy like Penn State
did it goes down correct and so I want
to have 10,000 admissions licenses
essentially so this is a a a ticket you
buy there's one of one you own it you
could decide if you use it if you gift
it or if you rent it out to a student
that year and it's going to pay you
rental income you're going to get a
piece of the revenue a piece of the
profits from the from the uh from the
from the tuition now I think that you
could sell these for probably at least
25,000 if not 50,000 each right so like
I think that's a low end for what you
can do if you again tell the story
properly and your boy's a good
Storyteller so let's say we get we end
up getting to $50,000 a piece we sell
10,000 of these um I just raised $500
million okay so yeah that's a that's a
pretty big initial set of funding but I
think you could do that to get this off
the ground without having to go get rich
VCS or billionaires to fund this thing
and so I think what you could do is do
maybe 10,000 or $20,000 per per seat
here sell 10,000 of these and you know
we're going to price these all in eth
that's just five eth five eth that you
own uh you know a seat at this
prestigious University and so I don't
know if I would do it year one but maybe
year two I would move to that once I
built a little bit of the brand momentum
and I would say uh you're G to own
something that's GNA pay you back every
single year so you might have spent 10
grand on it but you're going to get back
you know two grand a year or a$ thousand
dollars a year in in income plus you own
this prestigious asset that's going to
appreciate over time and you could sell
your whole seat later I think you answer
the out of this question
uh I think that's that's it's a very
compelling argument I would probably do
normal tuition but I understand that you
do normal tuition in addition that's the
beauty of these psls you do normal
tuition on top of selling this initial
seat it's just that person gets a REV
share of the tuition the biggest thing
that's wild here is that you can go onto
dealstream which I am and I'm looking at
universities that you can buy here's a
university for $8.5 million that you can
purchase fully accredited which I don't
know what the value of that is uh and
you get a campus y uh this particular
University had Peak enrollment in 2017
with 2 million in Revenue this is wild
Wild's one right here fully accredited
University Southern California a fully
accredited University in SoCal all right
25 million it's accredited its degree is
recognized all around the world they can
the school can offer F1 Visas so you
know we're getting that international
student money because you know who likes
being accepted into a hard to get into
program in the United States more than a
US citizen somebody in China and so
we're going to go ham on International
students we're g to you know uh that's
gonna be a big part of the marketing so
this says this the school has about 900
students enrolled in undergrad MBA and
DBA programs um there's one physical
campus and one branch campus so they I
think this particular one has it says
Title 9 is possible and I think with
Title 9 I think that means you get
government funding for sports yeah yeah
exactly you're eligible for for getting
funding uh from it and this is crazy
right so I would you know I would just
keep my eyes peeled for about a year I
would go around and you know one thing
that every rich person likes is the idea
of like fixing education and I would
just go tell them this is a school that
you would have wanted to go to right
it's a school that is um you know based
around people who actually build things
and make things it's going to be a
school that prioritizes projects over
lectures it's a school that is um you
know it's uh it's competitive and and
it's not online it's not online and
we're trying to uh build the next brand
these old Brands like you know even the
best you know the the Harvard's the
stanfords the whatever there hasn't you
know what where is the new one these are
like hundreds of years old There's an
opportunity to build something fresh and
we want you to be a part of it you know
I think that that pitch would get a lot
of people excited to cut you know mlion
doll checks I think that was a 9.5 out
of 10 pitch I think you did pretty good
you did a great job by starting it off
of what do you think Harvard's worth and
I'm like I don't even know unlimited
money not it's it's it's not even
sellable probably it's not even buyable
rather what's Stanford worth what's
University of pen I like it's I don't
know it's they're it's invaluable almost
um that's a that's a very good pitch
Bravo all right well that's that's the
episode that is the how to make a
million bucks and how to make a million
dollars uh from from your boys at my
first million a million and a billion
that's the
[Music]
pod